well the New England Patriots are
getting even more help the rich get
richer and we have confirmed that indeed
the New England Patriots have traded for
receiver Mohamed Sanu Chris I was
stunned by this one because I kept
thinking we were going to see that Sanu
would end up in San Francisco that'd be
kind of getting the gurgling and
bubbling around for a while but for a
second the Falcons got a second-round
pick for a guy that they just don't need
anymore and they're in fire sale motor
they should be this is a great haul for
the Atlanta Falcons is and for the
Patriots it's another you know another
effort to push the chips into the middle
of table and get to number seven and get
that extra help at receiver that they
don't have with Rob Gronkowski retired
with AJ with Antonio Brown gone and with
Josh Gordon injured now they've got
Mohamed Sanu he's a guy that plenty of
players on the team know well Steve
Belichick knows him from his time a
predator and it's another what a shock
another Rutgers guy playing for the New
England Patriots and this is something
that the Patriots have wanted to do for
a while and they finally get there and
and now they that the challenge is going
to be get him up to speed as quickly as
you can yeah that's right he's gonna
have some learning to do because he's
never been in an offense like this in
his history as far as in Cincinnati or
the Atlanta Falcons so this will be a
new language to him you know obviously
they're you know to get a second round
pick for the Atlanta Falcons I mean
great job by them I would think that
means there was a market for Mohamed
Sanu
and that's why the Patriots had to
eventually give up that second round
pick out of the fact that I think Bill
Belichick is going we're the best team
in football and our only issue is wide
receiver and we need more help there and
more versatility at the position and we
don't know exactly how banged up Josh
Gordon is but sinuhe's attitude he's a
guy that's he's been around the Sims
family before okay Mike he is hard nosed
New England type of guy and that's why
Bill Belichick likes those Rutgers she
knows guys or the Urban Meyer Florida
guys because they're usually can handle
the
day-to-day rigors of oh we play in New
England it's all business we're in your
face when you mess up we tell you how
stupid and bad you are and you need to
get better and Mohamed Sanu has the
toughness mentally and physically to
play up there in New England and you
know what else Mohamed Sanu can do
better than at least one member of the
Sims family throw the football so he can
family he knows that we helped him a
little there but he does he has a feel
to how to square to square the shoulders
right he's got a phenomenal not neither
you ever gonna take the ball out of Tom
Brady's hands but they do that from time
to time when you least expect it you
know you'll see something like that
where one of the other guys throws the
football and now Mohamed Sanu
and was that mix and this really I mean
I'm trying to process all this we were
thinking that the Patriots made a move
for a receiver it would be for a guy who
commands double coverage everywhere he
goes that's not the case this is just
another cog in the machine just another
guy who's gonna be on the field running
routes and if he gets open he gets the
ball and Tom Brady talked about that
last night as it relates to Jacoby
Meyers the undrafted rookie who had four
catches last night after having five the
week before against the Giants Brady
said I just throw to the guy who's open
and you know at a time when there were
so many teams out there to get
themselves all bottled up in the idea of
getting the ball to a certain guy like
Odell Beckham I've got to get it to him
early we got to get him engaged know the
best way to run your offense is the
quarterback is the center of the
universe the receivers run their route
and if you're open you get the ball yeah
and worried about the stats lay the
stats don't matter what matters is
running your route and making the catch
when the ball is in your hands yeah
that's all that matters in for the
quarterback all that matters is finding
the open guy and throwing it to him and
that and sinew is gonna fit that
mentality far more than here's some guy
that we have to feed the ball to over
and over and over again
definitely it's the beauty of the New
England offense they don't do that
really their plays are you know like I
was saying kind of in the opening today
you know you don't see Brady audible a
lot right if ever really he might say
check check or get to the other play
because he's called to plays but you
don't see him just like hey you do this
you do this hey do that do that do that
why because New England and like you're
saying is
well-oiled machine and every play has
the contingency plan for the defense
they're playing so he's been taught
during the week oh if they bring this
blitz I'm gonna go to this guy if they
play this coverage I'm gonna go one two
two three so he knows everything that
way it is the beauty of their offense
it's phenomenal that way and more
specifically with Mohamed Sanu you know
there's no tight end play there's the
tight end is not as important New
England this year without Gronkowski I
think they missed that middle of the
field aspect of their offense Sonu is
great over the middle as far as physical
not afraid of linebackers and safeties
he's a really good run blocker Mike so
when they bring him down close to the
line of scrimmage and want to run the
ball he'll go block safeties and
linebackers to do those things and then
oh oh we're gonna fake that we're gonna
run the play-action now he's over the
middle BAM you know so it's a versatile
group now with him and Julian Edelman
and Dorsett and we'll see when Gordon
gets back to where they can move them
around and to what you're saying you
can't get a tell on who are they trying
to get the ball to who are they
featuring know all our guys can do
everything in New England
well like the play we talked about
yesterday that fourth down in the
Houston Indianapolis game where the
Colts knew the ball was going to DeAndre
hugs right so you cover DeAndre Hopkins
and if you do that nobody else is even
in the route so yes that's what the
pages do and you were dangerously close
to suggesting once again that Tom Brady
is a system quarterback you have to give
him out of it for those 20 years of
experience where he knows when he looks
across who's going to be open he knows
what he see he knows it's that brain
he's got the supercomputer that is
attached to this body that for whatever
reason doesn't age and who the hell
knows how long he's gonna be I don't
mean it to be he's a system quarterback
the system's phenomenal and he runs it
phenomenal and he is always one step
ahead of the game and the brainpower to
your speak up I'm not trying to knock
Tom Brady I'm just trying to say it's
there it's so much bigger than just Tom
Brady at times on the offensive side of
the ball it's so brilliant what they do
and part of the brilliancy of what they
do is because of Tom Brady because he
has 19 years of a Rolodex in his head
where they can just go
deformation any play any contingency
plan we can throw it on Tom and he'll
get everybody straight in the huddle and
everything like that so I was not trying
to make a knockin like that there's a
lot of great quarterbacks who were
caught the same way I'm just saying in
New England it's beautiful harmony
there's always something for every
defense and just being up there and
experiencing it and playing for Josh
McDaniels I got to see it firsthand
where I just was always so impressed
that way I wasn't trying to take a shot
at Tom Brady all right let me let me
peel this back a bit because we had been
linking AJ green to the Patriots all
year long it just seems like a fit right
yeah do we think the Patriots offered a
first-round pick for AJ Green and the
Bengals said no and so it's a
second-round pick force anew because if
I can get Green for a one versus anew
for a two am I not taking green I'm
taking green yes a hundred percent but
maybe that's one but maybe Cincinnati's
not putting him out of the market like
we thought he might I mean they should I
think but yeah I mean I would certainly
take green for a first rounder over
Sinuhe for a second yes
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports